this is a you can show my screen this is
published actually same same moment that
herschel walker tough post kerfuffle
happened
march 16 2022 in the british
medical journal
bmj stands for british medical journal
yeah
an op-ed by two researchers called the
illusion of evidence-based medicine
uh subtitling being evidence-based
medicine has been corrupted by corporate
interests failed regulation and
commercialization of academia argue
these authors
and let me just read
this paragraph
which for some reason i've only
highlighted all but the last line the
philosophy of critical rationalism
advanced by the philosopher carl popper
famously advocated for the integrity of
science and its role in an open
democratic society a science of real
integrity would be one in which
practitioners are careful not to cling
to cherished hypotheses and take
seriously the outcome of the most
stringent experiments this ideal is
however threatened by corporations in
which financial interests trump the
common good this is not
antithetical to what desmond is arguing
it sounds like it might be but it's not
he does not argue that there aren't
possible financial interests that are
doing bad things in the world
he's just saying you don't need that in
order to see mass formation forming back
to the op-ed
medicine is largely dominated by a small
number of very large pharmaceutical
companies that compete for market share
but are effectively united in their
efforts to expanding that market the
short-term stimulus to biomedical
research because of privatization has
been celebrated by free-market champions
but the unintended long-term
consequences for medicine have been
severe
scientific progress is thwarted by the
ownership of data and knowledge because
industry suppresses negative trial
results fails to report adverse events
and does not share raw data with the
academic research community
patients die because of the adverse
impact of commercial interests on the
research agenda universities and
regulators
so that came out two weeks before the
together trial was finally published by
ivermectin are the together trial was
finally published but it's uh it's
rather in keeping
so uh it it actually is an excellent
place to make a particular point great
um the
we tend to think
of
actually i've been fighting this uh
battle a little bit since uh since back
in game b days when we say something
like capture
right
capture which is now a common phrase
since covid is a common phrase in most
people's minds
capture is a reference to an earlier
phrase regulatory capture and regulatory
capture was a much narrower phenomenon
than what we mean when we say capture
right capture is a very general
phenomenon it involves the capture of
university professors it involves the
capture of
newspapers it involves the capture of
all the things that
sway
policy ultimately
and the regulators are one that's one
core thing that you have to capture in
order to get ahead through this sort of
mechanism but anyway the point is
the proper instantiation for the concept
is not the specific one because if you
say oh what's going on is the result of
regulatory capture then people only see
the regulators and they say it's not a
big enough that that couldn't be doing
this and the point is no
zoom out right this is ex this is
extended capture as i think i've called
it before
and
unless you instantiate capture as
something in which regulators are
included but it is not limited to them
you won't understand it's its power and
so likewise the concept of corruption
right
corruption is corruption about uh
bribery and financial incentives it
certainly includes that but it can
include lots of stuff it can include
prestige right there are lots of people
who be
will be persuaded by prestige um
uh as you will remember i uh used to
argue about what what golf junkets were
doing why lobbyists were
taking their clients on
their clients is the wrong term but
their uh
targets
on
golf junkets and uh there was one
instance in which there was a whole lot
of prostitution going on in one of these
golf jackets and emerged and it struck
me that
essentially look
you want to figure out the two most
powerful incentives that you can use to
persuade uh at least men
uh are gonna be money and sex right and
so a lobbyist who can figure out how to
provide sex to somebody in a way that
they get away with it that their spouse
is non the wiser and all of that has a
very powerful tool you know we could
figure out what the value the equivalent
value is in money and it's very large
right
so anyway the point is corruption isn't
about bribery bribery is aversion right
and uh in any case uh what i would say
is
you have to instantiate the system that
uh the corruption of the system in terms
of the incentives what incentives
whatever incentives persuade people it
will include that full set right and
unless you're looking at that full set
then you will only have a partial
picture of why people do what they do so
you know the the authors there
um are arguing
uh about financial incentives and
desmond is saying maybe it's not
limited to financial incentives and
you're right they're the same story the
question is how narrowly are you zoomed
in right incentives persuade people
ultimately all of that stuff is driven
by
a system built to put your genes into
the future which none of these people
are talking about
right yes bribery is proximate to gene
spreading and gene spreading is now
crazy because lots of people are engaged
in
regulating their own production of
offspring and so they're interrupting
the very process that would unfold you
know that their extra power would give
them extra reproductive opportunities
which they're now not using for
reproduction
right but nonetheless
in what way will people be persuaded
every way that they can right right
[Music]
you